what we call modern science or which you
could almost call
super science not the notebook
jottings of naturalists and the
collated accounts of travelers but big
science where millions hundreds of
millions of dollars are spent on
instruments and coordinated
teams of people attack problem
this style of science that has grown up
in the 20th century
has had a very interesting consequence
which because it is spread out over
more than a generation we all
have grown up with it and haven't really
realized what an unusual situation
we are living in we are living in a
state
of constant scientific
revolution there is not a
single area that you can name
that is now seen
as it was seen let's pick a number
a hundred years ago nothing is left
of the world view of 100 years ago
100 years ago atoms were
billiard balls the basic building block
of the universe
indivisible uh
100 years ago the position of biology
was that darwinian mechanics
had just been enunciated in the 1850s
and was making its
way against an orthodoxy which held that
the earth had been created in 4004 bc
100 less than 100 years ago
when the cave paintings at lascaux
and altamira in southern france and
spain were first discovered
and experts came from paris to view them
after looking the caves over the experts
announced that these paintings were
obviously done
by soldiers in the army of napoleon who
had overwintered there
in 1816 and 17.
so
another i mean i'll give a few of these
examples
continental drift was unknown
the fact that the continent of africa
had an
edge which fit exactly against the
continent of south america
was mentioned in textbooks as an example
of god's sense of humor it was not seen
to signal anything
i can't think of an area in science
where we have retained the vision that
we had then
the earth was thought to be ultimately
stable pretty much as it had been on the
day of creation even by
the british geologists who were reacting
against
the story of biblical creation
but there's one area where surprisingly
little has happened and it is
strangely enough the area of the human
mind strides were made
in the early part of the 20th century by
describing the unconscious
but it's important to remember that some
of the hottest
therapies that pass through a place like
esalen
which would be things like
hypnotherapy mesmerism mesmerism had its
great heyday
in the 1890s of the last century
colonic therapy brought to a peak in
germany
in the 1870s um
reflexology a 19th century theory
homeopathy a theory developed in late
19th early 20th century
so we've not had in place
really new models of the mind
the body because of of wilhelm reich and
the many many schools
that he spawned either as his progeny or
in reaction
to his thought have given us new handles
on the relationship of psychology to the
body
but in the area of the mind it's been
pretty much
left alone well now to go back to the
previous example of these
other areas where scientific revolutions
were made
they were true revolutions
they were not fine tunings
or little additions of details but
complete
overthrow of old paradigms and the
establishment of new ones
the earth went from being a solid body
with continents pretty much
in the same places since creation to
a complex system of convection flows
where continents are brought together
and broken apart
uh man instead of being seen as
the highest product of creation a
descent
slightly beneath the angels is instead
seen as a primate
a specialized monkey of a certain sort
the hard atoms the indivisible atoms of
19th century physics give way to
fields first of all fields which are
characterized by action at a distance
which had always been excluded
previously i mean reason dictated that
action at a distance was a kind of
superstition
then james clerk maxwell demonstrated
that these fields
uh really exist
so in each of these areas a
total revolution took place
now the reason that
[Music]
psychology was immune to this i think
was because we did not have the tools
to advance it they came to us out of
ethnography and anthropology out of the
work of wasson
and hoffman and earlier have locked
ellis
and we're mitchell andre micho
all the people who worked with
psychedelics at first it was worked with
by
artists by literary people by people who
were interested in expanding their own
sensation but slowly it came to be
realized
that it was an insight into the mind
not into the nature of it so much
which i think still remains a mystery
but simply into its
size that the mind is a far
bigger domain than we
ever imagined we have somehow the idea
that that the mind is
in the head it's made by the brain
and therefore it must be a smaller
uh and less inclusive
domain than the domain in which it is
embedded
but i i brought along an example here
this is a box
and this box has in it
a box that is exactly
the same size as it is this demonstrates
how
even in three-dimensional reality
uh expectation can be
confounded
is itself a box indistinguishable
from this one and then this one
and then that one goes in there like
that
you know and can be closed into this
now that's what we're here to talk about
[Laughter]
it's just how to do that how to take
a world with a world in it and put it
into the world in it and put the world
in it outside of it because what we're
talking about and what history is
i think is an effort to exteriorize the
soul
and interiorize the body
to make the uh the fields of the lord
that we all sense inside us meadows
that we can actually throw our clothes
off and
wander into i think really what unites
psychedelic people is the faith and the
power
of the imagination
and science when it examines
the psychedelics as it will
and must is going to discover
a revolution i believe that will put all
the previous revolutions in perspective
and will show that they were merely
anticipations
of finding out this final unimaginable
fact
about nature nature whenever you scratch
its
surface has aspects that are
unanticipated
so when they looked at the shape of the
continents they discovered continental
drift
when wallace and darwin looked at the
distribution of butterflies over
indonesian islands
they suddenly had a vision of the origin
of species
and how that worked
the psychedelics are this immense tool
for the inspection of our own nature
and when we scratch it when we bring
that tool to apply
we are not going to recognize ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you